what's up hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast we're doing
something different and special today
but nonetheless you know what time it is
that is right
hot brethren and sistren this is the hot
breath podcast or a weekly guide to
comedy mastery I am your host comedian
Joel Byers and today we're doing
something a little different that I
think you're really going to enjoy this
is I will say the first day in almost
four years of doing this show that I
missed the Monday yes this is Tuesday
because some of you reached out to me
yesterday like hey where's the podcast
hey it's here thank you all that it
reached out showing support slash
concern but thank you also to those of
you that reached out showing support for
my comedy special taping I just did this
past Sunday September 15th right here in
Atlanta Georgia so that is why I didn't
have a podcast coming out yesterday
because hey I was busy trying to make
comedy history and a lot of you reached
out with you know support and
encouragement but also questions about
my process and the lessons I learned so
I thought it would be valuable all of
you listening to share the top five
lessons I learned from producing my own
comedy special this is good for comedy
fans and also comedians that are
thinking about doing this themselves
there are a lot of things I had to learn
the hard way that I want to make as easy
as possible for you so we're gonna jump
right into this this is a kind of a new
format as well I mainly do interviews on
here but this will be a good experiment
in just what you enjoy or don't enjoy
and I'm also going to be doing a live
Q&A about this topic at some point as
well so here are my top
five lessons learned from producing my
own comedy special so the number one
thing and by all means these are not the
only lessons you can learn from doing
this these are not the only things you
need to know to start yours there are
things that I will learn as I'm starting
to edit this and even as I learn as I
talk to other people who have produced
their own specials along the way so
these are just the things I've learned
just most top of mind 48 hours after
filming my special it's amazing
so the special is amazing but just
climbing that mountain has been amazing
and the first thing you're gonna want to
do is I mean it is a mountain it is a
lot of work so think about first why you
want to do this okay why do you want to
produce your own comedy special why do
you want a special out there why every
comedian and their agent seem to have a
special right now so it seems like the
cool hip thing to do and maybe you want
to be cool in hit or maybe you want to
get on Netflix or maybe you want to get
on Amazon or another platform or you
just want to release it independently or
you just want to have all this material
documented somewhere I mean really just
think and I'm not saying for all of
these lessons and questions I'm not
saying you need all these answers right
now I'm just saying take the time and it
took me time to find these answers but
take the time to really look at why
you're doing this and that's really
gonna help when it is 5:30 the morning
of your special taping and you're
driving back from Greenville to get back
in time to do rehearsal and set up all
the production and all that jazz like
it's a lot of work so having that why
will help to make all the work worth it
and also help to guide your decision
making because you're gonna have a lot
of options but knowing your why will
help to really hone in on the style and
the overall feel and mission and voice
of your special
because it's very important that your
special has your your own unique voice
and flair to it if you will because so
many people are releasing specials so
how can you make yours different that
could be a theme that could be where you
shoot it there's so many different ways
you can do it but it's just really
thinking about that ahead of time how
you can stand out so my why was to
inspire others to do the same so it's to
inspire comedians - oh hey we can DIY
this we can just make our own special
it's to inspire people sitting in a
cubicle right now that aren't comedians
but maybe have a passion for graphic
design or
for dance or for jewelry making is to
inspire them to create their own success
to invest in themselves and create their
own success so that's really the mission
behind my special along with of course
you know getting my face out there more
connecting with new fans getting this
material that I've been building over
the past decade out and documented
somewhere so I can move on and kind of
shake the etch-a-sketch and start fresh
but that's really my why and the main
core of it is to inspire others to do
the same and whatever it is their dreams
or passions are so that has really
helped to guide exactly what and why and
how so think about that you don't need
the answer right now some of you may
have it and that answer may evolve all
of my ideas of this special have evolved
and I'm sure as I start to edit it as
well that that will continue to evolve
as well and you know but the overall
core the overall mission is to profile
an authentic experience of a comedian
who's been out here on the DIY hustle
for almost 10 years creating his own
special and hoping to inspire others to
do the same and whatever their passions
the second thing is to who have a
qualified and trusted team around you
I'm telling you right now you can't do
it yourself
all right every successful person has a
successful team around them period and
that's something that took me trust me
several years to learn okay I wanted to
do it all myself and it's all me and I
tell you what it's gonna be on me and
it's gonna be amazing
they're you you need you need a strong
team you need a supportive team around
you so that could be just someone as
close to you as your wife my wife is a
has been a great member of the team and
helping not only fulfill the vision but
keeping me motivated and encouraged and
just keeping me inspired about what is
possible and why I'm doing it it's
always good to have that trusted voice
to help in the low times that know
you're doing this to inspire others no
one said it's gonna be easy but it's
gonna be worth it so having someone
close to you like that is very valuable
and even in the the team sense of
getting this done to the highest
standard possible so that that came down
to one my opener my opener Tyler
Chronicles who's been on this podcast
twice now he's been on hot breakfast
owed ninety two and one forty this is a
guy who inspired me to think bigger
in his first episode he was talking
about having this vision board and these
specific visions and these specific
goals all the way down to financial
goals to personal goals just goal
achieving and he had this vision board
and then when we follow up in episode
140 he has achieved all of these goals
and then some it's he's the first comic
that really showed me to think bigger
but also in a smart way to where it yeah
think bigger okay what does that mean
what what what do you want to do what
seems unachievable but making it a goal
and then work
towards it every single day you know
filling this special that it was a
mountain to climb that took a lot of
time and preparation and organization
and coordination but it was on the it
was on the goal for this year and we did
it but it was all really thanks to Tyler
embedding that mindset and I hope that
you know listen to his episodes I'm
linking those in the show notes or even
just hearing this little soundbite here
will inspire you to create your own
goals I mean he showed me the vision
board and I was like oh cool yeah that's
very cool and then he went I follow up
with him and he's actually done all of
them and then some it it's that's all
the proof I needed so he was actually
willing to come through the show open up
the show and just murder it and I knew
even my wife said she was like are you
sure you want someone better than you
opening your comedy special that's love
remember teammates
that's the supportive voice we needed so
yes I did because I knew he would come
in there and absolutely destroy the room
and make me have to work for it he's
legitimately one of the funniest people
on the planet and has been and it was a
just an honor with everything he has
going on right now that he was willing
to come he was actually headlining a
comedy club in Atlanta the same night
but he was willing to come through my
show first bless the stage so that's a
good team member to have someone you
know that you've learned from that you
guys can learn still learn from each
other but it's just it's an organic kind
of teammate along with I had my best
friend from high school come out Stephen
fine who's a film filmmaker out there he
just released his a awesome film called
love shot it's on Netflix and Amazon and
all that jazz and he flew out the
afternoon my shows at 6:00 p.m. here he
landed it 2:00 p.m. came straight to the
theater and then left the next day for
like a 10 o'clock flight so that's a
teammate I just needed there so he was
willing to make the trip and he's
someone that he's kind of like the Larry
David to my Seinfeld if you will
just like he's been my right-hand man
since we were freshmen in high school
and just a teammate I needed there to
help he actually operated one of the
cameras we had a few cameras roaming
around but he was he actually was
operating one of them so it was cool to
have them and in speaking of the
production side of if we want to get
more in the weeds on just you know who
to work with and even where to do it
first things first the venue where do
you where do you want this to be okay
and yes this is all still following
under the umbrella lesson of having a
qualified and trusted team so the venue
I picked the basement theatre right here
in Atlanta this was actually the first
venue that ever headlined me ever
headlined me like this was oh maybe like
three years in the comedy the theaters
been around for like 15 years the owner
J star is a fan of comedy he's a fan of
supporting comedians and I knew this
would be a place that would support this
production in terms of giving us the
flexibility to come in on a random
afternoon see where we want to set up
cameras and then get in the venue again
and see how we want to do the audio
setup and like it's I just I worked with
a venue that kind of you Joe Pettis on
here who's one of the top show producers
in the southeast and he said you want to
work with venues that want to work with
you same thing with your special okay
work with a venue that wants to work
with you wherever that is
so this place just had a special place
in my heart and a special place in
Atlanta comedy and I wanted to shoot my
first special there so that's why I
picked that venue so whatever venue you
pick just make sure there's a personal
organic reason to it beyond just oh well
that's that's where all the cool kids go
so that's where I want to be give it
some heartfelt thought and when it comes
to the production team I hooked up with
my man Dante who actually if any of you
know I did an online course with
frequency media here in Atlanta which is
uh
it's a podcasting production Network
I mean they've worked with people like
you know Apple and Salesforce all these
big companies they produce podcast for
and we actually collaborated on writing
and filming an online comedy course all
right not online comedy course online
podcasting course so I can link that in
the show notes as well if you want to go
check out just the trailer it's a fun
it's a fun theme we came up with but
Dante was the sound guy on that set when
we filmed and I liked how he worked I
liked that he was professional and very
knowledgeable and very nice and I was
like this is someone I'd like to work
with so got his information when I
locked in a date I was like hey are you
available to help with my special and
he's like let's do it so I I separated
I've heard horror stories of people just
hiring a video guy and being like all
right do everything all right you can do
the sound and worry about the video and
everything it's like I separated the two
responsibilities so I had a video crew
and I had Dante the audio engineer I
want to make sure I worked with people
that are very well versed and what they
do and just let them do what they do
okay
now the video team probably could have
done audio but it's like it would have
taken away from their ability to do the
video because now they're trying to
think of this like it's just the easier
you can make it on your team the better
so I was like hey let me hire an audio
guy and just worry about the audio for
him and then I have a video team just
worry about the video for them and what
I'm also going to do with the audio is
make this an album as well so it's gonna
be a comedy special but also an album so
I want to make sure the audio was as
crisp and clear as possible for that
album and special of course so I hired
Dante to take care of that a
professional audio engineer yes I
invested in professionals because I am
producing a professional comedy special
and finally when it comes to the team
the video team now I worked with blind
Lincoln Productions family run business
run by Isaac Stackhouse he also produces
podcasts for people and things like that
but blind Lincoln is his like video
production arm and how we connected
right here do the podcast he was a fan
of hot breath he reached out wanted me
to be on his podcast I did his podcast
the daily stack and we just kept in
touch and I realized he did all these
cool things and I was like hey I'm
thinking about producing this special
what do you think and not only not only
and this is why it's important to have a
team because if I just asked the video
guy and I was like hey will you just
come fill my special and be like ok cool
I'll show up the day of and film a
special but Isaac was super hands-on and
even just what we want the feel of the
special to be and also he followed me
around like three weeks prior really it
would be cool to document this so who's
following me to open mics to road gigs
all the way up til the day of the
special documenting the process so this
this special has grown beyond just like
your standard comedy special format and
a big part of that is the team so really
think about the team and the team
evolves and grows okay I thought I was
gonna work with one one group of people
on the production side but it has since
evolved but even the people I thought I
was gonna work with they have been so
hands-on in just providing whatever
insight they can and whatever feedback
they can into not only the production
but also just the story and what I'm
trying to convey so they've become they
didn't necessarily video the show but
they have become creative consultants
and just the overall vision and feel of
it so just just um you know don't get
too hard-pressed in your ways just let
the team kind of organically form okay
this is
yeah I think this team has been building
over the past 10 years it's not like I
just woke up January 1st and was like oh
there's my video guy
there's my audio guy there's my opener
it's it's a process okay but I'm hoping
this episode it just inspires you to
start the process and it is a process
okay so moving on to episode 3 let me
take a swig of my hot breath water real
quick mmm Pontus I mean you guys know
the water I was giving away waters at
the the comedy special taping people are
like oh I'm never drinking this like I'm
leaving this there were people there at
the show I like signed waters it was
really cool so moving on and speaking of
team I mean fondest water you know
thinking of the podcast those of you
who've been listening for a long time
you know they've been making custom
labels for me for years so it's cool and
this water bottle was on stage with me
at the special that's for the culture
there they even asked me to do it so
moving on that was all having a
qualified and trusted team that was
lesson number two listen number three
being prepared all right because that
may seem obvious but I've been working
on this material and it's been
accumulating for almost 10 years now so
I've been working very hard at
developing this material and I thought
it was all just gonna kind of fall in
place I was like oh I've been doing this
almost a decade I know the material
it'll just all kind of fall into place
but and I just focused more on okay the
production side I need to get all these
things in line and should I have
sponsors or what's the theme like I was
worried about everything but the actual
show for a little while and then it kind
of hit me about like two or three weeks
out I was like oh I'm like telling a
story like yes I have all this material
but it's like how can I weave it into an
organic story that took a lot of
preparation by preparation I mean the
Saturday before the show I'm standing in
my hotel room rehearsing the entire set
over and over and over again actually we
don't Instagram live for those of you
that follow me actually want to
Instagram live and just showed the
rehearsal process set up my camera in my
hotel room and just showed me rehearsing
the entire comedy special and taking
notes as I go
that was something I did not anticipate
I was like oh I know the material that's
the easy part
and then it was starting to come down on
the wire and it's the day before and I'm
like oh no I don't know the material
like in the order I wanted it to all
kind of weave in so with the preparation
came a lot of open mics which blind
Lincoln was following me around for
three weeks leading up to it we
documented a lot of me going to open
mics and then I was at Star dome for a
full weekend working out the set in
Birmingham and then I was in a
Greenville at the comedy zone there the
following weekend the weekend of the
special working out the set so just to
let you know the day of the special I'm
up at 5:30 a.m. and Greenville South
Carolina driving back so I can get back
in time to just get everything organized
and get to the theater so we can get set
up from production wise and to do a
rehearsal because I did another
rehearsal before the show so I'm in
there they're setting up cameras and we
do like a dress rehearsal where they're
playing around with the cameras and how
they want to shoot it and I'm running
through the entire set so yeah
preparation and that why preparation is
so important is because it's it just
gives you the confidence so when it is
so by the time it came to Showtime
and I was about to go on I was like all
right we're ready we're ready for this
all right you've put in the work now
it's just time to enjoy all the work
you've done but I will say
for my next comedy special I will be
even more prepared on the set side
because I was cramming and it did come
down to the wire more and for the next
one I definitely don't want to do that I
want to have the set like hammered down
and check that off the list because I
mean I'm in the green room before the
show even just like making my setlist
and kind of just running through all the
bullet points in my head and it's it was
a nerve-wracking
but we got it done and it was exciting
and I'm excited for you to hear and see
it but with that being said and me
saying I want to I did this to inspire
other people to do and pursue their own
passions and if there's a very comedian
and you you're like oh I want to do my
own special just remember as my fourth
lesson be patient okay
like be patient in this process like I
said this team didn't form overnight
that took some patience for it to
organically form be patient in the sense
of are you um are you doing a special at
the right time you know it that can go
back to your Y as well so is a special
what you need to do at this moment
because I can tell you that from
personal experience I had been offered
to tape a special twice before producing
my own and this is where someone else
would have produced it so I'm so
grateful I didn't go down that Avenue
and no offense to them but it just it
just the timing wasn't right it just
didn't feel organic I was honored and
flattered that they would even ask if I
wanted to do it but it just wasn't the
right timing so I actually turned down a
couple offers to do this earlier in my
career and I could not be more thrilled
so think in
patience of oh my gosh everyone's
producing a special and I don't want to
be left out and I don't wanna I want to
have a special with my face on it you
know just be patient okay
half of this game just just focus on
getting funny first okay I didn't even
think about oh I need a special or I
should be doing an album or I should be
more wha I don't even think in terms of
like business or branding until maybe
six or seven years in before I realize
okay I have a funny product that I'm
willing to start sharing with people I
just I put my head down and just hit the
stage for like six or seven years
straight just working just trying to get
as funny as possible so when I do feel
like I have something worth selling I
can do it with confidence because I know
what was the last lesson I'm prepared
exactly so maybe a special isn't maybe
this isn't the time for a special but
hey maybe record an album hot sister in
Sam Severin one of my favorite comedians
and she's right here in Atlanta she was
actually hopper episode 147 she produced
her own comedy album so she came on here
and talked about that process and you
know what the comedy album which you can
get on iTunes and all that jazz and I
will link her episode in the show notes
her comedy album was like 20 minutes
long so there's no right or wrong to
this okay she had some material she was
proud of at her at this juncture in her
career so she recorded it and made an
album just the success of finishing
something will give you immense
confidence that oh well what else is
possible like I talked about with Tyler
giving me that mindset
maybe maybe start there you know just
record a quick little 20 20 minute album
just start there just chip away at it
did you don't eat it all an elephant in
one
but that all comes back to your wife as
well okay why do you want a special or
why do you want a comedy album and most
importantly to me number five I talked
about you know being prepared being
patient and also number five being ready
I mean is when you record an album or
you record a special this is forever so
is this how you want to be perceived
Prima I mean do you want this on your
record forever I do that I have a
checklist that I go through when I'm
approached with projects and some of
those are like how will this look in
like five or ten years is this this is a
project I believe in do I care about the
outcome of this project or am I just
doing it for a quick buck same thing
with your you know your material you're
doing right now and if you want to do a
special it's like okay well how will
this look in five or ten years am I even
ready to do this and I even ready cuz
trust me trust me I know and I've
interviewed almost 200 comics who have
shared the same sentiment that we at
times can take our eyes off her own
paper and start looking at what everyone
else is doing and like oh man well
they've got that I deserve that they
aren't even funny
it's or well they're over there well
that's a good idea I'll just I'll do
that too because it worked for them I'm
telling you right now one of the main
lessons I've learned in doing this
podcast and interviewing so many comics
is that there's no right way there's
only your way okay so really keep that
in mind in the being ready aspect I've
been doing comedy almost 10 years and
that's not a passive ten years it's not
like I've been kind of doing an open mic
here there may be performer once a week
or whatever I mean this is litter
like this has been my life for almost 10
years just eat breathe sleep comedy and
how can I get better so leading up to my
10 year I thought this would be the
perfect timing to do a special and
really at the beginning of this year the
goal started out as is I'll just report
I'll record a comedy album this year
that'll be a good step in to introducing
myself to a bigger audience but then I
met blind Lincoln and realized oh this
can be bigger you know so just just you
know be ready don't embarrass yourself
don't embarrass comedy okay especially
with how much comedy is out there the
more quality comedy we can get out into
such a saturated market the better it's
gonna be for comedy you know all what is
it all rising tides rise all boats or
coop scuba or all melting IceCaps raise
sea levels so all boats rise okay so be
ready let me drink a little more water
by the way you can you can get some of
these waters to shoot me a message on
the website and I'll ship them to you so
websites hot breath podcast calm or Joel
Byers comedy calm and also in being
ready you know this is an investment not
only time so luckily I had the time to
help put all this together because
comedy is my full-time job which wasn't
until about six or seven years in after
I had built up a nest egg and enough
enough of my network and enough skill
set I felt like that I could become a
professional and start touring around
and making a living at this
so being ready in the sense of skill and
also being ready in the sense of
financial investment you know this is
not something to sell your house for you
know I mean this is a moment in my
career where I'm
willing to bet on me so I am going going
to the blackjack table and taking my
cards and being like this is what I'm
playing well you got dealer the dealer
being life we're gonna see what the
dealer has for us
but I feel ready and I felt prepared
which gave me the confidence to make
this financial decision so I knew I
wanted when I did a special I want to
look professional I want to look
polished so that requires you working
with professional and polished people
you know and that comes you get what you
pay for in this game I'm sure you've all
at some point cut corners in some way
whether it's on a t-shirt printer or
it's on like a sound guy it's just at
any level you've tried to cut a corner
and you got what you paid for either
immediately or down the line you know
you go and buy some of the you know you
go and buy some cheap clothes somewhere
because they look cool and then as soon
as you wash them
those pants turn into capri pants you
know so make sure you want to invest and
knowing your why will make your
investment kind of goal more clear so I
knew I wanted to as the Y inspire if we
want to talk directly to comics inspire
comics to DIY their own success invest
in themselves and do it so I didn't you
know I remember seeing Andrew Schulz who
been on here you know his he taped his
own special and put it out because no
one else would pick it up and now look
at him he has created his own success
but his special I heard him say on Joey
Diaz podcast it was like 25 or 30 grand
so for most of us it's like wait wait
wait is there even that much money in
the world
so I I wanted to do it at a price point
that is attainable for people as well I
wanted the production quality to not
suffer but also show people that with
the
team you can create a quality special at
a reasonable price but there is a price
that I was willing to pay to invest into
me so then hopefully inspire you to do
the same when you are ready and when you
are prepared and when you have been
patient so I hope that's been helpful
y'all you know the vision with this is
to inspire others to create their own
success this is all this will start out
did video and audio so I'm releasing it
as an album and a comedy special but
what I want to do moving forward here is
really hear from you I've had people
reaching out with questions and things
like that and I want us all to come
together at the same time and kind of
have a discussion about this topic
because so many people are doing comedy
specials and you're like you can get
FOMO of like well whoa maybe it might a
Miami to Commedia if I don't have a
special so it's it's your why why do you
want a comedy special ok make sure a big
theme of this has been make sure it's
just organic and it just naturally fits
so what I'd like to do is
today is Tuesday September 17th oh and
anybody in Chattanooga I'll be in your
city tonight so pull up on a kid if you
listen to this the day of so let's do
Friday September 20th at 1:00 p.m. I
want to do a live Q&A about this topic
so where we want to do this is at the
Facebook group the hot breath comedy
Network so if you're not a member of it
yet we have almost 200 members now it's
so great it's growing if you're not a
member yet go on Facebook and I will
link it in the show notes as well but go
on Facebook
and search hot breath Comedy Network
requests to join let me know how you
found the show and then you're gonna be
connected with listeners from around the
world sharing tips and tricks and
favorite moments of the show and it's
just kind of like a town hall for all of
us to come together so this Friday
September 20th at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time
I'm gonna be on there doing a Facebook
live Q&A answering any questions you
have about producing your own comedy
special all right so let's connect you
know that's why this podcast has grown
into a county mastery platform not only
for me to learn about comedy but to help
other comics learn about comedy the
right way because we have mentioned
comedy is becoming more and more
saturated so the more quality comedy we
can create the better comedy is going to
be so that is a mission of this show for
sure
helping people suck less at comedy
that's the new tagline but if you did
enjoy this as well please please PLEASE
not only go join that Facebook group but
connect with me directly and also for me
you know at Joel Byers comedy and let's
just I would love to hear what you liked
about this and if you want to hear more
episodes like this because it has been
more interview driven but if there's a
moment like this that's happening in my
career as you think you you all have
learned that even in how I steer my
interviews some of it is like well this
is the point I'm at in my career do you
have any advice for me so I'm learning
as well as you are and we're kind of
learning together but anything I can
help to share along the way if there are
other kind of topics you would like me
to discuss in this more long-form topic
topic long-form conversation please I
would be interested to hear from you
because that's how we learn and grow is
from each other so I hope you enjoyed
this I enjoyed doing it I enjoy doing
the special so as we recap
top five lessons learned from my DIY
comedy special my why getting a
qualified and trusted team being
prepared being patient and being ready
so that is all that is this week's hot
breathless ode hot brethren and sistren
thank you so much for tuning in oh my
gosh I had a blast doing this so I will
see you Friday
September 20th at the hot breath Comedy
Network Facebook group for a live Q&A
about this topic I love you and until
next Monday
right here on Oh even at this episode
I'm gonna have to thank my wife at the
end of it so thank you to you that
listened or watch this thank you to my
wife Aaron Byers who not only made the
theme song for this show that you're
hearing right now that theme song she
made on Garageband we also got a dog her
and the dog we're sitting front row at
the comedy special and the dogs gonna be
incorporated into the show as well
you'll see you got a you got to see the
special but now that I think Tara I can
now close us out with until next Monday
right here on